[Applause]
i think people just want
them to they want to feel like knowledge
so if a black person is saying
yo this country's [ __ ] up blah blah
blah there is racist yo there is
absolutely racism sure
if you're going to say there's not
progress i can't agree with that because
there has been progress do we still have
a long way to go sure yeah
you also can't and barack obama said the
exact same thing on the marine podcast
it was great you can't you absolutely
cannot say progress has not been made
there is just evidence that has been
made do we have work to do of course
yeah relatively speaking and so do a lot
of customers give you evidence that's
changed like for example like it used to
be
if you said hey i can't catch a cab
because i'm black i'll catch cabs so
[ __ ]
it wouldn't be true you'd be like you
know what this probably racism can i
tell you something though let me tell
you let me just say this let me just say
this let me finish this
you saying you can't catch you get
probably used to be true right but
now in 2020 if you're black and you
can't catch a cab let's be honest
yeah when's the last time you saw a
white taxi
driver it's not gonna happen 1973 yeah
it was a movie directed by martin
scorsese i don't think they exist now
if you're blind if you're not getting a
cab you got to take that up with the
south asian community
if you're a black right now yeah yeah an
uber you got to take that up at
that up with [ __ ] metropcs that's got
nothing to do with colby or
carter yeah and that's that's where
cumberland harris might do the most the
most prob make the most progress is we
might get less anti-black
uh what do you think of it do you have
trouble getting a cab alex but i do
ubers
so kids got a tesla they don't [ __ ]
take out but the thing is yeah it's like
to me it's like yo if you black you've
got to get a tesla so the cab driver
can't be racist
it's like you know i got artificial
intelligence doing this yeah but i'm
saying if the cab driver
is not going to tip it's probably if the
cab driver is racist
it's probably not a white guy who's
being racist that's my point yeah
the thing is but i think if you're black
you don't care that they're not
whatever race they are that still feels
racist but there absolutely
there's racist but there's racism but
there's racism
in every single race right i mean every
race
doesn't like another race for some
reason even within their own race
that's how trouble we are even even even
john is sitting here right next to me
and again i
am in no way shape or form diluting
american slavery and how brutal it was
to the african-american population was
horrible
it's no way shape or form but giannis's
family giannis actually had someone who
was enslaved in his family because when
the greeks were enslaved by the ottomans
up into the early 1900s so so you
actually have people walking around
today who's can look at someone who was
enslaved
where it but if i said that to someone
in like if you know in black america
they'd be like [ __ ] you
we were we had it the worst and he had
it horrible but my point is that
so many groups of people were enslaved
humans as janus said before
are just inevitably shitty people and
will do things to [ __ ] subjugate
other groups and it's just gross yeah
but so but to say
you know white people are systemically
racist and destroying america in 2020
is it's tough it's getting tougher and
tougher to swallow but i agree with you
where i'm like
hey if this person had uh you know
things go on fine but we're all walking
bags of chemicals
dude i have billions and billions of
neurons in my head having different
chemical reactions than you every second
of the day so
i may see things a little different than
you but it doesn't mean we're bad people
yeah if we're leading with love if you
got to leave with love and also you mean
you just look at the word slave it comes
from the word slav
it was when the ottomans were enslaving
people of the caucasus and in slav they
were white
and even even to this day right now
there's uh saudi arabia still listening
to
the most enslaved people ever existed
right now i mean uh
abu what's it called ali dali
dubai was built
was built by um south asian
quote-unquote slaves i mean they were
indentured servants of slavery yeah by
arab [ __ ] i'm amazed we did that well
there because we also went to trinidad
and you see how we built that [ __ ] is
look shoddy work bro you guys are slaves
you know but i'm sure you spoke about
this
i'm sure you've spoken about this on
flagrant two before where you know
racism it's it's monetized now there is
no incentive at all for news networks to
get rid of racism they would lose money
they have to keep it alive they have to
look for every story
that might have the slightest hint of
racism in it because if they don't
who's going to they people hate watch
more than anything they need to talk
about a lot
i think this maybe not that thing
specifically but 24-hour news
is dangerous sure because you need to
constantly feed a beast
sure like [ __ ] who watching news
for 24 hours a day
3am you got news on we need something
that makes you stick in front
stick to that channel in front of the tv
back the day was 30 minutes hey this guy
got murdered that guy got murdered in
local politics
all right done even now and i don't know
what the story is so i may be speaking
you know prematurely but there's a boy
who just was died in louisiana and it's
horrible on his
and he was found in a river and i think
his face was like um
it looks a little bit like mmt and they
have it so emmett
of course was a racist horrible thing
that happened where the people got away
and that's brutal and i would never
stand for that but this boy
nobody knows what happened to him nobody
knows how it happened yet there's no
the police are still investigating they
don't know but yet already the narrative
is
look how much he looks like emma teal
which is fueling people to be like
racism somebody did that somebody did
that when none of that stuff is true yet
but it's already getting in people's
minds for him why
because he looked like emmett thiel they
put it up and because they're trying to
have this subconscious racial narrative
going on
and a divide to jump up their numbers on
the media that's what i believe
yeah i mean there's racism i mean there
is black
you see some [ __ ] like peop where you
are reminded and you're like okay
i want to see what the [ __ ] is going on
because i think i know how this looks
yeah
and there's a difference between that
there's a gray space between that
and this is automatically racist i don't
need the facts [ __ ] it i also understand
the skepticism because cops have covered
up so much
of course for the past 200 years that
they're like i'm not going to believe
this
it's dangerous when you just jump to
that conclusion and then you go i think
the problem is like when
when news became content and when
journalists got twitter
and they were trying to get followers
and stuff like that they didn't really
adapt to the internet and they started
using the same model
that advertiser model where we got to
get clicks to get paid yeah
and so as soon as news stopped being
subscription based
news and started being like more it's a
talk show now yeah it's a talk show yeah
and like i worked my show i had and why
is jerry the number one why was jerry
springer the number one talk show in the
90s controversy
fights fights [ __ ]
it's car crashes even even sheltering
even chelsea's youtube numbers when they
were big jumping a lot
if you looked at the comments a lot of
it in was fighting in between about
stances he was taking if you got people
fighting in the comments that's
the algorithm [ __ ] you tech companies
and then you lecture
us about morality when you've set the
[ __ ] algorithm up
for people to fight go [ __ ] yourself you
do the same thing that cable news does
you've turned this all into [ __ ]
rubber neckers that are pulling over
to look at a car crash on the side of
the [ __ ] road go [ __ ] yourself
silicon valley you pieces of [ __ ] dog
[ __ ]
from the east coast with love [ __ ]
recount the vote
[Laughter]
you know i had a show on fusion which
was all owned by abc news
and it was it was a new show yeah it was
like we were trying to be like a
millennial good morning in america
how happy are you that you're done with
that [ __ ] i wanted to have it sounded so
miserable oh it was probably
a couple hundred grand coming back but
let's get to christy because but let's
be honest you were living in miami you
were skinny mean and you had some
pieces passing through i had a couple of
pieces passing through the apartment i
had floor-to-ceiling windows
every month you stay in miami one more
button comes down
you are
you can tell somebody's been in miami by
how many every month of buttons comes
down but here's the thing
this was their motto i'm pulling the
curtain back a little bit so people know
this is the truth
the truth is abc news best in the
business good morning america
kelly and michael whoever's sitting with
that with her now you know
um the the motto really is pick a fight
pick a fight right that's what gets the
most attention that's what gets rating
that's what they
that's what they would tell us pick a
fight yeah so
that's what they're doing that's what
they're doing they're picking fights
so the problem is you know people see
that and somehow
something happened around 2012 when
people started to think
that it was real that like that like ann
coulter really
cares it's [ __ ] theater yeah you said
ann coulter came to stand and was
laughing at [ __ ] i mean it's
theater and then she goes and writes a
[ __ ] book and says we're losing this
country there's [ __ ] mexicans
crawling in my soup
no there's not probably both sides do
this but the biggest mistake i see
the left make with this kind of [ __ ] is
they always feel feel that fire
i didn't know who tommy lahren was until
she was in peace and wanted to [ __ ] her
i
if she's got a hot husband i'm in um
you know what else too social media
obviously we know this
but it's almost like now i'm being
people i i'll i
think maybe in years from now we may may
see this in a grander scale
but i genuinely believe like russian
bots
and and you cannot just you cannot count
them out
that they might be fueling a healthy
majority of the actual race-baiting
going on in the country i saw somebody
get uh a black guy i think it was
stanley from the office the man who
played stanley from the office he posted
dms that he got that were racist saying
the n word and horrible things right
and he posted this is the type of stuff
i live with and and all those things
and then all the comments race race race
i wouldn't put it past russia
that they created some bot to send those
messages i know
that people do do that i know there's
disgusting racist people
and all that i know that but because of
how easy it is to manipulate that
algorithm and how easy it is for the
russians to make these bots
to fuel racism and divide us from well
you can tell when you get hate fake
comments because it's always
the first name and then ten numbers yeah
i wouldn't discredit them at all where
and but some of them look like so real
where i'm like unless it's i've made a
choice as human being unless i
physically see it happen
in my actual physical realm if i see it
on the news or on twitter instagram i
just
i discard it i don't let it get into my
system because i'm like you just can't
tell what's been manipulated
who's telling the truth who's not
there's too much of it so i try to make
my life small
if i see something that's horrible i try
to act on it there or if i see something
catch my attention i act on it there i'm
not worried about what's going on
all over the world because too much of
our data is manipulated and i just think
it's too risky now
it's a it's a total enron
bernie madoff pyramid scheme where the
tech companies inflate
engagement by allowing these bots and
these fake accounts
right to increase engagement to increase
to increase engagement so they can tell
their shareholders and their
their public owners look at how many
users are on here when really
there's about a fraction of those users
that are real
and the rest of them are just digital
bots or fake accounts that are there to
sew discord
and they look the other way with that
right because
they profit off that and then if you say
a certain thing
they [ __ ] flag you so it's like just
like a sociopath who pretends to be the
opposite of what he is
to cajole you that's exactly what the
tech companies are doing
that's exactly what social justice
warriors do they're
hiding and obfuscating the fact that
they're [ __ ] people and they're
all about themselves by putting up the
scropes the smoke screen saying i'm here
for all victims
because nobody questions you if you say
hey donate to this charity if you
retweet a charity that says donate to
this charity
i'm a good person or if you point out
somebody else's flaws nobody's gonna
question you because they're looking at
the person
it's a [ __ ] tactic it's transparent
and we should be on to it now especially
since that kid tristan is now talking to
the media yeah it's what it is
back of the wizard of oz and the wizard
of oz is a little chinese kid
that works at tick tock that's trying to
destroy us they named it tick tock
because they know the end is near
they know america is almost over and
they're just sitting there going
tick-tock but
there's times saying in chinese that
[ __ ] yeah piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] app
is full of pedophiles and devil
worshipers
that little chinese kid whoever made tik
tok in the same petri dish they made
tick-tock to wuhan weezer and yao mint
[Applause]